[Musique]
un tournoi qui ne passe pas inaperçu
dans paris marie-josée nappe sous la
direction de son mari michel derache
tourne actuellement avec mohamed chouikh
l'adaptation du bo est grave roman de
claire et shereni élise ou la vraie vie
m
[Musique]
michel bras marie josé nat et mohamed
chouikh vous tourner tous les trois avec
des efforts conjugués élise ou la vraie
vie alors je voudrais d'abord demandé au
réalisateur
si c'est pas quelque chose d'un peu
inquiétant de tourner un film où il y à
ces mots la vraie vie qu'est ce que
c'est la vraie vie michel bras la vraie
vie pour moi c'est de faire du cinéma
déjà et puis de faire les films que
j'aime ce qui est le cas en ce moment
c'est assez rare la vraie vie c'est des
moments de sa vie assez rare je voudrais
demander à marie josé nat si elle
n'éprouve pas la sensation jeudi pas de
7 ans lady pour ce film parce que ça
paraît difficile mais d'avoir emprunté
un personnage un peu différent des
autres que ce que vous en pensez
je suis tout à fait je suis très
contente parce que elle est un
personnage merveilleux et j'ai la chance
grâce au roman de claire et shereni de
pouvoir interpréter ce rôle
[Musique]
je sais que beaucoup de comédiennes
révèle
m choi que je crois que c'est un de pas
de tout à fait vos premiers films
français
c'est mon premier film français en
réalité je fais d'autres films et s'est
pas fait en algérie mais c'est le
premier film que je fais en france
est-ce que c'est pas un peu une gageure
de tourner ici au métro barbès avec tout
ce monde
vous avez tous l'air absolument kahn
très détendu moi je vous admire
il faut tourner ça comme si on était en
studio c'est pareil et puis je trouve
qu'il ya des éléments vivants qui sont
formidables il faut pas dédaigner je
crois qu'il est un peu difficile ici de
donner le synopsis du film et le
scénario je crois qu on se souvient du
roman de claire est gérée lit de toutes
manières selon lui et ceux qui n'ont pas
lu doivent le lirai pas c'est un roman à
une échelle drache c'est pour quand la
sortie de ce film ça j'en sais rien
parce que j'ai commencé sans
distributeur je n'en ai pas encore je ne
sais pas du tout quand sortira en mai
chez que nous avons beaucoup de plaisir
à le faire qu on est très heureux de
faire
[Musique]